why did it take ten years for this film
to be made we had the film optioned and
then bought out by a really great
independent producer and a great
director and then they couldn't get the
money together or something and we were
just you know kind of poor you know kids
just sitting around waiting for them to
do something and then it just kind of
got they bought it out because they
thought they were gonna make it and they
didn't and then it got stuck at Fox
after a while they all left Fox and Fox
then the studio itself didn't realize
they even had this screenplay
so it was a little loophole with the WGA
Writers Guild about getting your
screenplay back most people I should say
don't get their screenplays back but
this particular screenplay it's a small
script or it's a small premise and we
should all be had a shot at buying it
back for the price we sold it for which
was not very much and we asked Fox if
they would give it back to us and you
know they did you know they gave it back
to us for the price that uh we basically
for the price that we they bought it for
and we went and made it but we had to
wait with that clause the WGA clause you
have to wait five years you have to wait
five years after the last rewrite or the
last active it's called active
development and a studio will find any
way they can to not give you back your
script they'll you know active
development can be misconstrued as
anything I mean you know that could be a
lunch I mean they could say anything
that's not really illegal it's so loose
you know but Fox they simply simply put
they just didn't really know that the
screenplay was in their vault because uh
the people who had brought it in and
left and we got it back did you lay
awake at night thinking I want this
screenplay back or it was more of a
process where it came at the right time
the five years was up
it was more in the back of my head when
I had heard about this this this WGA
clause the five-year thing which was
like a couple months after we had been
we had done like a quick rewrite on it I
kind of just set my internal back of my
head timer and Jason Dolan the
screenwriter the screenwriter uh we just
kind of set it in our heads that you
know whenever it was 2016 I think it was
we are able to we reacquire the
screenplay and by that time I think I
had just made my first feature and and I
was able to attract more interest to
make a second feature and so the timing
was right on him but but really to be
truthful I actually didn't necessarily
want to make the movie I just wanted the
script back but you know we made it
you